ja na ja ich liebe dich oh das ist ja
lieb von dir und ich hab dich so lieb
du hast nicht zurück gesagt ich liebe
dich das ist schon mal ein guter start
in unserer heutigen episode denn wir
wollen heute darüber sprechen wie man
auf deutsch seine liebe ausdrückt und
zwar mit welchen worten es gibt
verschiedene sätze im deutschen und wir
werden jetzt mal die leute hier auf der
straße in berlin fragen was sie sagen
und wem sie vielleicht welche sätze und
welche ausdrücke sagen los geht's los
geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wann haben sie das letzte mal jemanden
ich hab dich lieb gesagt vor einer
halben stunde auch als nachricht gerade
fertig ich glaube von paar tagen hat
sich mit meiner mutter telefoniert habe
sicher sagt man hat spanier deswegen
sind ein bisschen anders da war also
gerade bei einer spanischen familie zeit
die zuneigung mehreren freunden feiern
ist ein bisschen was getrunken hat so
dann sagen sie was auch gerne noch immer
gesagt dass ich wieder fragen wir also
ja also gerade so und du redest du deine
montag spanisch ja ja immer wann haben
sie das letzte mal zu jemandem gesagt
ich hab dich lieb
letzte woche und zu sehen zu meinen
söhnen
ich bin raus wann hast du das letzte mal
jemanden gesagt ich hab dich lieb
ich hab dich liebt das habe ich gerade
vorgestern einer freundin unserer
familie gesagt die mich schon kennt
seitdem ich ein jahr alt bin
und die ist jetzt fast dies jetzt 88
und die hat auch ausgedrückt das muss
man ja auch mal sagen weil wir deutschen
das nämlich eigentlich nicht so viel
machen wir sind ja eher zurückhaltend
und drücken das nicht so in worten so
viel aus
also als mehr trainerin da sah ich das
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als die
deutschen
ich glaube ich habe das schon gestern zu
einer freundin gesagt also in einer
sprachnachricht sagen was wir sagen am
ende sagen wir einfach ja hab dich leben
und wie drücken sie ihre liebe
zueinander auswahl
eigentlich gar nicht mehr also ich hab
dich ganz gern ist eigentlich so das
möchte ich es so ist das maximum
sozusagen ja also ich liebe dich würden
wir selten sagen schatz auch mit
denn einige sagen schatz mein schatz das
sind aber die die sich die namen nicht
merken können und was sagen
oder sagen sie da sage ich liebe dich
ich liebe dich aber meistens auch ich
hab nicht mal 1 gleich an
na ja ich nehme dich also weiß ich nicht
und ich vermisse dich oder sowas
und was hast du ja dasselbe dass ich
vermisst so dass die liebe und schätze
visier ist da ich würde sagen ich würde
mir glaube ich die person dann zu mir
rannehmen bestimmt in einem passenden
moment im tief in die augen gucken und
wirklich vielleicht erstmal den moment
genießen gucken schießen
und dann sagen hey ich habe tiefe
gefühle für dich und ich möchte dir
sagen ich liebe dich und was sagst du
deine frau wenn sie sich so richtig
richtig verliebt fühlst dann wird
irgendwann mal ich liebe dich
rausrutschen aber da wurde dann schon
immer gemeckert das ist nicht passiert
aber ich sage es wirklich so ist ja auch
schon ausgenutzt langsam dieses ich
liebe dich gleich am anfang man muss ja
wenn es vom herzen kommt dann ja das
sagen also wir drücken eigentlich unsere
liebe mehr dadurch aus dass wir viel
zusammen machen also wir machen zusammen
sport wir arbeiten beide von zu hause
aus mein mann auch schon vor kurve
zeiten und wir machen viel zusammen wir
essen viel zusammen wir machen sport wir
gehen wandern und alles mögliche aber
dass wir jetzt so ganz oft sagen ich
liebe dich weniger da sind wir doch noch
sehr deutsch
[Musik]
wusstet ihr schon dass sie auch mit uns
ketten könnt und zwar jeden tag was ja
ja wir haben doch tatsächlich eine
schleck gruppe mit unseren mitgliedern
in unserem community tier wie ihr wisst
haben wir eine mitgliedschaft seite und
die heißt patrick dazu laden wir euch
ganz herzlich ein bei bachelor- / german
und dort könnt ihr verschiedene
mitgliedschaft modelle auswählen und
eines davon ist eine chat gruppe mit
janisch und mir und easy und manuel und
vielen anderen aus unserem team und dort
schreiben wir jeden tag zu ganz
verschiedenen themen und einmal im monat
telefonieren wir auch zusammen
[Musik]
was sagen sie zu ihren kindern das
gleiche ich liebe dich ja ich liebe dich
bis zum mond und zurück
bei uns in süddeutschland gibt es ein
begriff wie hedge herzkirschen auf
badisch herrscher des quasi so süß und
so groß und so saftig unser roth wenigen
tischen
das ist wunderschön ich hab dich ganz
doll lieb kleiner bub ich ganz ganz ganz
doll lieb und was sagen sie zu ihren
eltern
ich liebe dich ich sage ich hab dich
lieb aber ich kenne auch leute die sagen
ich liebe dich gesagt glaube ich liebe
dich zu hause oder ja aber selten sehr
selten da auch da sage ich liebe dich
mama meinen eltern umgehend zu sagen
dass ich sie liebe
dass ich dankbar bin dafür dass sie mich
großgezogen haben also das irgendwie zum
ausdruck bringen und ja dankbar für ihre
unterstützung bin also durch dankbarkeit
glaube ich würde ich ihnen das sagen ja
ich sage eigentlich immer ich habe euch
ganz doll lieb stadt ich liebe dich also
sage ich auch zu meiner freundin selten
erst wenn so richtig ernst gemeint ist
aber also eigentlich sage ich immer ich
hab euch ganz so lieb
manchmal sage ich aus spaß ich kann euch
ganz gut leiden ja das ist doch toll
meinem eindruck nach ist dieser ausdruck
ich liebe dich im deutschen etwas was
man eher selten benutzt im vergleich zum
beispiel zu dem englischen ayew in
meiner erfahrung sagt man ich liebe dich
eigentlich nur in einer romantischen
beziehung und auch erst nach einer
gewissen zeit und manchmal kann das auch
etwas tricky sein oder etwas sensibel
wenn man zum beispiel nicht sicher es ab
wann man diesen satz sagen kann mit
einem partner oder wann vielleicht
dieser satz erwartet wird und das ist
vielleicht interessant und speziell im
deutschen ich würde zum beispiel zu
meinen eltern nicht sagen ich liebe dich
sondern ich würde sagen ich hab dich
lieb und nur in einer beziehung würde
ich sagen ich liebe dich
und was ist der unterschied zwischen
diesem ausdruck ich hab mich lieb und
ich liebe die ich hab dich lieb sagt man
zu allem und ich liebe dich nur zu zudem
partner und vielleicht brüder schwester
man kann auch einen freund wie ein
bruder liebt ich hab dich lieb ist eine
software variante was man normalerweise
zu freunden sagt ich glaube weil man zu
schüchtern ist um zu sagen ich liebe
dich aber ich nutze hauptsächlich auch
mit freunden ausdruck ich liebe dich die
würde ich es eher so romantisch und nur
wenn die andere person das wirklich
versteht oder man sich wirklich einig
ist darüber was man von den beziehungen
hat dann kann man das auch mal sagen
aber das muss dann von vornherein klar
sein ansonsten ist eine romantische
sagen gesenkt
und stell dir vor du verbringst du einen
abend mit alten kumpel und irgendwann
wir die klammern ich mag diesen menschen
wie vermittelt oder sie also eigentlich
habe ich da keine grenze zwischen
freunde familie also ich freunde sind
auch eine art schon von mir ist wie
gesagt ich den hut auch dass ich dich
liebhabe also genauso dann würde ich
wahrscheinlich sagen da habe ich das
schon mal gesagt dass du dich so so
liebe
das war ein schöner abend mit euch
vielen dank für den schönen abend
ich würde sagen es war so schön sich
endlich einmal wiedergesehen zu haben
und ich hab dich richtig kann ist ja ich
glaube so werde ich sagen ja so nach dem
motto hey ich feiere dich du bist ein
guter freund von mir ist ja sehr
körperbetont so und umarmen sich und so
weiter also gerade machen daraufhin oder
münchen geflossen sind sondern dass er
körperlich zu neigend auf jeden fall
arbeiten im slang feiert du du bist echt
geiler typ und so nach dem motto na ja
so in die richtung geht es war immer
mein schmuck
man sagt hab dich lieb und dann hängt
man noch um was witziges hinten ran um
das alles aufzulockern nicht so ernst
wie oft sagen wir eigentlich zueinander
dass wir uns lieben schon fast zu ruft
ja auf jeden fall er auf jeden fall wir
nehmen wir uns anders wenn jemand bei
uns ist dann sagen wir das seltene aber
wenn wir alleine bringen dann sagen wir
es schon fast so aus spaß
wir sind tatsächlich ein sehr dankbares
pärchen wir sagen uns jeden tag dass wir
uns lieben einfach um uns daran zu
erinnern und uns zu freuen dass wir
zusammen sind und wir möchten jetzt mal
von euch wissen wie es das in eurer
sprache wie sagt man auf eurer sprache
ich liebe dich und welche anderen formen
gibt es gibt es zum beispiel auch so
einen unterschied zwischen ich liebe
dich ich hab dich lieb und wann in
welcher situation benutzt man welche
wörter schreibt uns mal einen kommentar
wir freuen uns auf eure antworten wenn
ihr lust habt mehr zu üben mit diesem
video und auch transkripte und
interaktive übungen zu bekommen dann
laden wir euch ein
ein mitglied zu werden bei patchen
dankeschön janisch dankeschön
[Musik]